is the younger brother of the wind
hashira sanami and he actually eats
demons in order to gain their power by
eating the Flesh of a demon Genia is
able to temporarily gain the physical
characteristics of that demon the extent
of the Demonic power that genya gains
depends on the strength of the demon
whose flesh he consumes if he eats a
weaker demon he will still gain some
demonic abilities like the ability to
regrow a lost tooth or the ability to
recover from wounds that would have
killed a regular human but genya is at
his strongest when he consumes the Flesh
of upper ranked demons which he manages
to do twice if you want to know more
about genya's powers and tragic
backstory and if you want to know which
two upper moons have a part of their
flesh consumed by him check out my full
video on genya and his powers Link in
the description and in the pinned
comment